those movies never never like oh we're
coming for you
Voldemort used to do hard drugs dude and
now you're like I need no jellybeans
what's in the box what's in the box I'm
Nick Monday he'll rudnick and we're
basically gonna dive in here man on
screen junkies they send us a lot of
toys a lot of crap they need somebody go
through all this stuff make sure don't
slow make sure it works properly get all
the cool out of it right away before
they pass it off to people in the office
that's our job all right here we go cut
the tape and let's find out what's in
the box okay come on dude this is the
Nimbus the Nimbus 2000 dude this is
Harry Potter's broomstick all right not
the official one from the movie but the
one they market for children these are
real bristles you can actually sweep the
floor with this but more importantly
you're supposed to use this for
Quidditch and to fly around man let's
see what it says the instructions are
Princeton jump on broom fly me very
suggested I'm flying I know but it's
like why is fly look at that why is fly
in red and in quotes does that seem like
sexually suggestive to you like fly me
or you think they're going it doesn't
really fly kids
yes so that this is basically legal
disclaimer so before I can even have fun
with my nameís mm the legalese the
lawyers come in and be like flying is in
red because no people can really fly
let's see you could practice Quidditch
just like Harry Potter
look at this kid with the blown back
hair man having the best time ever if
you ever enjoyed anything that much in
your life
yes bankin look I've done that plenty
over the course of my life but I've
never won that expression no that's
amazing
nothing in life I've had a child and I
didn't have that expression on my face
imagine like if you were imaginative kid
you just grabbed a broom running around
the room bill goods members mm but
you're rich kids you got no imagination
whatsoever they needed a plastic
and they said to their hoity-toity
parents mother what does a broom and
then they had to explain what brooms
really did in the real world meanwhile I
was able to ride my Nimbus 2000 because
I was sweeping up the kitchen because
that's what I did as a child I'd heard
my keep the scroll on said chores yes
well let's look what it does first we
have to read what it says man first
there's this hard sell every Quidditch
and Quidditch has a trademark after it
which is really disappointing it's like
can't I just get into the world whenever
I read a Harry Potter book it didn't say
Quidditch TM after it like I get it you
own it I'm not trying to steal it every
Quidditch player dreams of riding a
Nimbus 2000 yes now just like Harry
Potter and Harry Potter as a TM after
his name as well did you imagine every
time you read the book you were like TM
TM TM it's nuts
you could train with the Gryffindor
Quidditch team on the gold standard of
broomsticks practice your best seeker
moves and keep your eye out for a Golden
Snitch this is all sex talk nice active
golden salt and smash is my code word
whenever we're like multiple person
scenarios I'm like Golden Snitch if it's
too much for me I'm like don't kiss her
like yes it's got reinforced tail of
twigs and by twigs that's not that's
plastic no tree is made of place
horsehair
yeah right it's got a power button yes
as a broom still for for probably noises
ooh electronic flying action the fastest
ever flying experience broom does not
really fly look at that they take all
the fun out of on the front at the
instant code so at least you could be
like wow maybe we're flying stuff
but right here on the back room does not
fly come on shut you down real quick how
about how about put this is not a broom
like that's even even bigger warning it
doesn't fly but technically doesn't
clean either it's like a slap in the
face could you imagine if I was handed
this as a child nerds said sweep your
room with this I'd be like this looks
too fun Nimbus 2000 flying lesson move
power button to the on position
okay jump on your broom and grip handle
and take off oh I'm gonna call [ __ ]
take off we're way me run around then
say run around don't say take off you're
setting his kids up for disappointment
what if this kids on a roof and he only
read the first two instructions and he
went no further and there's
well is what the box told me to do I do
what witches and boxes tell me to do off
that kid goes man he don't get to number
three
Paul broomstick up to fly higher so even
if he does get to lesson three that kids
like everything copacetic this is
exactly as I dreamed it would be
Paul broom handle down to dive back to
the ground me tell you something kids
you don't even have to do that if you
jump off a roof of this between your
legs you will go straight to the ground
point handle left or right to turn now
is this just come on
this is embarrassing for all of us hold
broomstick straight to hover Oh all of
this is the noise that it makes it's not
making empty promises to children let's
see how it works men all right wait a
second
I said what is that is that the noise of
a broom
I guess the Nimbus 2000 I've done a lot
of sweeping on my life this is not the
sound of a broom the sound of a broom is
this hmm because you're Roman this is
exhausting yeah well it takes a lot of
providing strength I don't have any of
that so a few sweeps of Rome and I'm
like I'm winded ma I take a break it's
sound she say yes have a devil dog put
your hand right here where your crotch
would be brown
no I'm saying yeah it's the Nimbus 2000
bong tickler you ain't kidding man it's
like a rabbit if I had to guess the
value of this when and this is the first
Harry Potter movie directed by Chris
Columbus the guy who gave us
Bicentennial man yes Chris Columbus I
would say you run the first wave of
excitement of the movie everybody's like
ah these books have come to life 30 35
560 99 the original don't look you
looked the original price for those
playing along at home I'm like this
jagged so close 1999 this could have
been yours you could have your kid get
out of their own vibrator for 99 and not
feel this ribbed for his and her
pleasures like this is not a toy for
children bring this home give it to my
wife face and be like look you use this
and I'm Dumbledore this is why the boys
face is so excited now oh my god I used
to like Legos I used to stick him in my
nose but this makes me funny in the past
guess what they're getting for it now
because there's been a few Harry Potter
movies and as you know there's a massive
broom shortage in the world so how much
do you think this items going for $69
you just want to say 69 hundred to a
hundred and five dollars could you
imagine don't pay that for this go buy a
real broom for like two bits give it to
your kid and be like [ __ ] pretend
that's why I did my kid get my sense of
reality and stuff they pulled it from
stores when it became clear the teens
were using them as vibrators no when
they debuted there were for sale in sex
stores around Times Square for 40 bucks
you could have bought this at a Toys R
Us or you could have went to a really
dinky rinky-dink like adult store and
been like I would like to buy this for
sexual gratification and boom you'd be
double the price down double the price
but triple the pleasure of riding a
regular broom as Mattel's marketing team
thought Quidditch toys would be the
biggest Harry Potter time could you
imagine they were like the Quidditch
team to be huge yeah this fictional game
where kids fly around that kids normally
can't do in real life it's gonna be huge
of course it can't be huge man won't you
step on this and all it does is tickle
your balls the magic of Harry Potter is
over
like what are we playing again here we
go best Amazon reviews even my
daughter's friends enjoy playing this
fun toy I was surprised at how long they
could just sit in her room and play with
this magic broomstick yes I played with
my magic magic broomstick for hours in
my room they tie and if I have friends
over that sounds hot could you look at
each other like oh no right let's ride
our brooms and look at each other let
make sounds while you're getting so your
parents like oh they're and they're
having a good time but really it's like
you and me riding brooms and one huh
here's another great review my only
problem I see with the toy is the
batteries drain too fast and his sister
fights him over it so now I need to buy
her one oh my sister you're gonna have
to buy your own and then she's in the
room and all you can hear in the house
is the sounds of physical love could you
imagine if every time you climax it's
that it was the noise and I'm gonna try
to duplicate that this evening with my
wife that's kind of what I sound like
what is his name Walter Matthau in that
movie man IQ wow that's an Einstein
that's Einstein coming let's try it out
for me I really want to take it out of
the box I do I want to fly around the
room knowing that it's a hundred and
hundred fifty dollars man like when you
rather resell it Nimbus 2000 plus we
don't even have self two kids dude put
this stuff on eBay and be like it will
make you come hard
mm-hmm you can break your wife's rabbit
and sell this to you I'm like you're
done with this she's like I had a
vibrating egg that was incredibly
discreet I got him public with it now
you want me to ride this I'm like yeah
vibrates listen you don't think we
should try it why they do you want to
see if it feels like an Amazon review
here we go watch your fingers step back
already all right oh there was another
one well good thing you took care of
them all right here we go hearing is the
Nimbus 2000 oh look at that it says
Harry Potter officially right in the
handle just like Harry Potter's broom
wood all right show me how it works I
got to break this off ah the magic
stopper magic is about to begin in
earnest kids then you turn it on there's
always something stopping the magic oh
that's what I'm saying son solid
vibration you would you know how long
you would have to like and how deep you
would have to push this into anything to
get any sort of like pleasure out of
this hey if you're young and sensitive
that is you're like 18 19 yeah okay nice
yeah that's an 18 19 year old I think
most kids were great man but listen to
you if you're young and sensitive how's
it feel do you feel it at all and you
feel let me hear you push you pull it as
tight as you can up to your business and
now I'm gonna give you something all I'm
gonna do this which feels better
turn your head which feels better that
for this actually feels so good on my
bottle mommy tried my balls that was
even a benefit of a t-rex jumps out and
grabs you everyone salutes you like now
let's see if it does let's hear the
noises here this is where you put your
this where you're supposed to sit that's
the sound okay
that's a dance move you like do the
Harry Potter oh you heard up and see
when it makes the noise it vibrates more
so the goal is to not only so there's a
reward if you play this I'm telling you
it works um so what you're saying is if
you keep throttling about something
wonderful whoa just Kim
anyway this thing I can understand a
little bit what's going down here but I
wouldn't spend 150 bucks huh
no especially we can use your hand for
like nothing it's pretty cool I could
see kids not liking it
it's pretty cool I could see kids hoping
this sorry I was thinking that but let's
see let's see if this works - that's
functional as well very multi-purpose
come back here Oh so imagine think about
it like everything you've ever used to
get off in life yes has it also had a
dual purpose no you know what I'm saying
like does your fleshlight sweep the room
as well well this is that's where this
algum has it all over again you could be
like this
thank you bike alright okay and then
you're done and then you go oh wait let
me clean that up brush well use yes much
thank you a long time with a brush most
of us use a gym sock wait there's more
one more thing in the box kids here we
go
Bertie Botts every flavour beans you can
take one I'll take okay okay so the idea
of the Bertie Botts every flavor being
at least in the Harry Potter books and
movies is every bean tastes like
something else but it's not like you
know cherry strawberry chocolate some of
the flavors are like booger stuffing if
I remember correctly yeah not like you
know man
juice or anything like that you have to
worry about if you taste something tell
me what it is we're gonna taste these
get rid of this box alright so what we
have here is a bowl Bertie Botts beans
okay you and I are gonna try beans and
try to guess the flavors all right okay
I'm ready to try I'm ready I'm gonna I'm
gonna let you know these are just
regular old Jelly Belly jelly beans but
with different flavors they didn't do
all the flavors in the books like some
of the flavors in the books like
dog food they didn't do that but they
did do some weird flavors okay
including I'm gonna give you fair
warning there is a vomit flavor and
according to this factoid I was just
received the Internet
you know that is yo yeah they report
that it takes up to two days to get the
vomit beam taste out of your mouth so
you may pick a bomb it bean and it may
be with you for two days you're my wife
may kiss you be like you think you'd be
kissing pukey girls getting a huge fight
jeopardize your marriage can't do it
don't pick the vomit one I'm gonna hope
not I mean they don't know what color
the vomit what is them I'm hoping bonnet
wouldn't be gray so I'm going great okay
okay most obvious apartment color there
is yeah I would
that's where I'd hide the vomit in the
griot home get out thank you what it
tastes like
you're not gagging so either you like
vomit or it's not vomit
kiss it [ __ ] really let me try what I'm
gonna try this one is orange and it's
got little specks on it
you got the vomit one bye everybody
you got the Bobby yes that's what Bobby
tastes like oh wow what about doing it
here baby bird go down here
I hate JK rowling ma'am I ain't had
vomit in my mouth
mmm that ain't mine at least two weeks
how can they sell that man that's a that
should be against the law dig and eat a
whole fistful I'm just treating now I
had the word no I really want to try to
guess all you have to do is avoid the
orange I'm gonna try yeah I want to
taste the brown one wonder what that is
and then I'll try mmm red seems they're
gonna be pretty spicy absurds but these
are the ones I'm going for kids first
I'll try the rainbow color one because
I'm thinking magic bubble gum bubble how
do you get bubble gum and I got vomit
tutti-frutti all right what did I pick
orange red eye even orange guy did not
wine taste you
like my being I get down no you don't
what do you got dead tastebuds I really
don't you kill them all the drugs and
stuff
no all right one last one I don't know
the red one is like on the road wasn't
super good [ __ ] Jerry it's a good cherry
here we go last one flew I'm sinking
blues gonna be something gross but not
too gross
you spit milk tastes like milk good no
now you're trying to make me eat it mmm
no what is it like laundry detergent
like really I get a dye yes we call
nine-one-one said induce vomiting
I'll be your mountain Bluebird I don't
know what to say it reminds your fabric
softener smell or something that's
that's good I tasted great britain
rainbow blue they haven't I tasted the
only one that tastes like vomit that's
the joy of Harry Potter's Bertie Botts
beans
I'm gonna go light green with little bit
of dots I'm thinking it's like booger
flavor some see I could deal with booger
flavor vomit though we got like grass
like a harness not that good grass Sam
it tastes like cut grass it's not very
good but there's a grass it's grass okay
there you go I've tasted grass my
friends well the good news is like if
they were ever like we need somebody to
tell us what each of these beans are you
could do it with like 10 hours you're
like hey sweetness let me think about it
how much I'll try another one but I'm
praying it's magical root beer
yeah but beer begun you don't say it
like supportive yeah Ruby every good but
that's gonna be [ __ ]
oh I'm assuming there's a lot of brown
still if there's brown with black marks
in it like yeah you eat that one good no
I have one seven man point out that you
used to do hard drugs dude
intravenously and now you're like I need
no jellybeans I am eating done I ate six
the other one with the Browning
oh here we go white we yellow that's
like popcorn
oh that's really gross what is it I
don't know it's gross oh but you've had
it uh-huh what is that rotten egg oh my
god how does it taste like sulfur and
stuff yeah that's really gross
all right there you go man I've had
booger I write grass yeah I had vomit
which Trump's them all
I don't know rotten eggs bro is this
what kids do like when I was a child we
weren't like let's put horrible things
in our mouths here we go
all right all right it's bad something
happened yeah a bit and like instant bad
came out
that's probably brought that's probably
like fart fart Buster that's a flavor no
I don't know I don't want this familiar
because then when it's like your
mother's vagina they look like now I
don't know this dirt earthworms oh my
goodness RJ like dirt eyes had a like a
veggie shake before I got here as I put
a beat in there it tastes like that oh
my god is horrible you if you do it no
no no no that's to put them spin them
out look out my God look how many you
got you have to award that some I want
to get the same I gotta get him oh hold
on ready one two three
just follow him no working $2.00 [ __ ] oh
it was like the injustice league in my
mouth no there's too much going on like
bubblegum cherry mmm he tastes like the
Florida grocery store what else we good
oh that's all good so far that's a bet
everything trying Botts every flavor
beans
uh I don't try it unless you know this
is good party game mm-hmm good like
truth or dare of the 21st century you
know what I'm saying like I dare you to
eat this for use your hand off me or
something like that that's kind of thing
that I could see us doing
well not us together but well yes us
together but still this is not for the
meek apart man and neither is this so
there it is folks you wanted to know
what was in the box we dug into the box
and we ate things that's who we are the
icon entertainers we are your like put
this in your mouth we're like okay oh
you want to see us open other things man
let us know what you want to see us open
doesn't matter what it is right to the
screen junkies man on their Twitter page
or on Facebook and tell us what you want
to see us open up man or send us some
[ __ ] - oh yes you just send us some
screw stuff you got for Christmas that
you don't want you send it us we'll open
it for you man so until next time man
I'm Kevin Smith
JCM you come back next time to see
what's in the box what's in the box
[Music]
you